be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos rights playing things outside
of comic books so as we get back into
the pattern of DC rebirth what I want to
do here is have a discussion on
Nightwing and what I'm hoping is that at
the end of all this you'll walk away
with a better understanding of Dick
Grayson as well as what DC rebirth means
for his character regarding the
foreseeable future and so much like the
rest of DC's rebirth line of comics
Nightwing gives us a return to the pre
new 52 era of his character while
combining it with popular elements from
the new 52 to sidetrack here when DC
initiated the line wide reboot of their
various characters teams and universes
Dick Grayson stood as one of the handful
of characters being watched closely by
comic fans the reason for this was that
whether it was due to these fans having
grown up with his character or because
there were newcomers who found the
Nightwing concept intriguing the fact
remains that many wanted to see a
continuation of existing concepts prior
to the start of the new 52 what I mean
here is that if we reference my video on
Dick Grayson explain which you'll find
in the description his character was
originally introduced in 1940 as the
sidekick of Batman in order to draw
sales where this was largely successful
in that young readers loved having a
reflection of themselves in comics
following this 45 year long stent in
1985 going into crisis on Infinite
Earths and after having served as part
of the wildly popular Teen Titans DC
look to break Dick Grayson away from the
role of Robin operating alongside Batman
allowing the position of Robin itself to
be filled with a new creation and Dick
Grayson to come into his own to this end
and under the writing of Marv Wolfman
Dick Grayson was remoulded in the
Nightwing having taken the name from a
hero operating within the bottle
Kryptonian city of Kandor as a result
and in the post-crisis continuity Dick
Grayson found a special place in the
hearts and minds of comic fans and that
while he did operate with the Teen
Titans themselves he also had his own
rogues gallery and city to protect in
the form of blood Haven and even
operated his Batman following the events
of nightfall and Final Crisis all while
maintaining a position as one of DC's
top tier heroes however with a launch of
new 52 dick Grayson's traditional
history of being part of Hayley Circus
as a family act and witnessing his
parents death was modified to reflects
goth nighters vision of Batman which
established
my circus was designed as a front for
the court of owls a secretive
organization operating out of Gotham
without Batman's knowledge and using
Haley circus to monitor and recruit
children who had become a talent for the
court following the child's growth into
adulthood and eventual death using this
as a jumping-off platform with Snyder's
Batman run moving incredibly fast
Dick Grayson fell alongside the other
members of the bat family regarding
Bruce's ordeal with the court of owls
the return of the Joker and the Joker
subsequent discovery of the bat family's
identities where writer Kyle Higgins
kept most of the publications in line
with Snyder's Batman as tie-ins on the
whole the stories of Nightwing under the
direction of Higgins were hugely popular
and where the stories didn't sell as
high as Batman himself it maintained a
respectable average of about 45,000
copies sold each month on the other hand
with Kyle Higgins departing with
virtually no information on why if the
rumor mill is to be believed the
creative direction of DC going into the
post forever evil line of stories
differed from Higgins vision leading to
his removal his writer to be replaced by
Tim Seeley covered in a 2014 interview
with comics Alliance Tim Seeley had
stated that prior to coming on board DC
had already made the decision to move
Dick Grayson away from being Nightwing
Antony to cancel a line and replace it
with Grayson which focused on spy
related content
now we're see Lee's information revealed
that the idea wasn't fully fleshed out
when it was originally pitched with the
first several issues the story was
extremely popular coming out of forever
evil which saw dick Grayson's identity
revealed to the world during an invasion
of earth by the crime syndicate an evil
version of the Justice League from earth
3 after being connected to a device
called the murder machine designed to
kill the individual trapped inside as
well as those around them Lex Luthor had
intervened stopping dick Grayson's heart
in order to trick the Machine into
believing that Grayson was dead allowing
Luthor rescue him and engineer his
escape alongside Batman Catwoman needs
cyborg using this a transition into
Grayson with the world believing him
dead dick was shown as having given up a
life of crime fighting and instead
focuses efforts on operating as a mole
for Batman within spiral an organization
ran by Helena Bertinelli a new 52
reimagining of the Huntress who is
viewed as the most wanted woman in the
world and heir to the Sicilian mob with
this story was critically acclaimed by
fans due to Seeley focusing on both
Grace's life as a spy as well as
attempting to keep the world from
becoming aware of his existence the
lead-up to rebirth came during the
events of Batman and Robin eternal a
two-in-one style of storytelling which
focus on the past and the present with a
pastel with Batman and Robin facing
scarecrow for the first time the present
events operated as a counterpart to that
man in game focusing on Dick Grayson
alongside the rest of the bat family
facing off against a villain named
mother who looked to initiate a
worldwide collapse of the industrial
financial and social sectors believing
that the remnants of humanity would
create something better at the
conclusion of the event and due to the
defeat by Batman the court of owls came
to believe that in order to defeat
Batman himself and guarantee their
control over Gotham the group needed to
recruit Dick Grayson to this end and
with DC rebirth being initiated under
the direction of Geoff Johns the long
game for dick Grayson's writing came to
a head with the introduction of the
Parliament of owls a long suspected but
never confirmed centre for the various
court of alle factions around the world
with Tim Seeley returning his writer
much like the rest of DC's rebirth
titles
Nightwing rebirth number one provides us
with an expectation of his character
going forward picking up with Dick
Grayson at an arcade we also learn that
he's spending time with Damian at a
sidetrack for a second where dick
Grayson's character was being fleshed
out in the new 52 by Tim Seeley writer
Patrick Gleeson was fleshing out the
character of Damian Wayne taking place
in the 13 issue limited run Robin son of
Batman the work of Patrick Leeson took
place after the disappearance of Bruce
Wayne at the end of Batman endgame and
followed Damian himself as he looked at
form his own legacy outside of simply
being Robin tying in to the events of DC
use Robin war which sought Damian Dick
Grayson Jason Todd and Tim Drake forming
a gang called the Robins where the
group's purpose was to take down the
court of owls permanently in Batman's
absence because the ongoing goal of the
court was to recruit Dick Grayson Robin
war led him to Nightwing rebirth by
revealing that the court had planted
explosives in the mind of Damian now
where this did not appear to be
something anyone outside of the court
was aware of what Tim Siri tells us is
it Dick Grayson had actually known for
quite some time with Damian questioning
dick about his time fighting alongside
both the Huntress and Midnighter
what we learn is that
has Helena Bertinelli was returning to
her position as Huntress to fight
alongside that girl in birds of prey and
midnight it was more akin to a vigilante
than a traditional hero the life of
engaging in lies duplicity and
manipulation goes against the moral
compass Dick Grayson had formed both
during his time as Robin as well as his
time under the Nightwing moniker
however while fighting Midnighter prior
to his departure Grayson was provided
with the device that would allow him to
safely extract the explosive from the
mind of Damian without fear of killing
him after which the two were greeted by
the arrival of Batman now were dick
Grayson's initial response is that the
courts attempt to procure him put Damian
in danger something to point out here is
the subtle line that exists between the
two within the bat family while each
member has faced their own struggles and
the Batgirl was paralyzed by the Joker
Jason Todd was killed by the Joker
Dick Grayson lost his family and Tim
Drake's struggle to keep Batman in check
following the death of Jason Todd
because Damian is the biological son of
Bruce Wayne
he holds a special place among the ranks
of the bat family as a result and in the
minds of dick the loss of Damian would
be far more substantial than if any of
the other members were to perish a claim
is supported by Batman's reaction to
Damian's first death during the events
of that man Incorporated
however this issue is effectively
quelled when Batman informs Dick Grayson
that he saved Damian's life and that the
blame for Damian having a bomb place in
his mind doesn't reside with Dick
Grayson and instead resides with Lincoln
March at a sidetrack for a second during
the initial launch of the new 52 writer
Scott Snyder had begun sowing the seeds
of future characters and Batman stories
by reintroducing or retconning a myriad
of individuals with Lincoln March
standing among them under sniper he was
established as having been the possible
brother of Bruce Wayne a claim that was
never officially verified now whether or
not this was something Snyder introduced
reveal is a question I don't have the
answer to but with that man each kernel
operating as a companion to Snyder's run
the storage salt Lincoln March returned
by gathering villains like hush and
cluemaster
for the purpose of taking out Bruce
Wayne while the endeavors of Lincoln
ultimately failed because of his
rashness
the court of owls had have secured for
the purpose of turning him into a talent
at some point in time now to be honest
I'm not actually as current as I should
be in Batman comics so I can't give you
a reason for his return to the landscape
but after petitioning the Parlin
owls to cast aside their white masks in
favor of a black mask he's immediately
shot in the eye by Raptor a newly
introduced character as part of
Nightwing rebirth who operates as a
freelance assassin working for the
Parliament of owls and so with a comic
winding down and coming to an end after
transitioning back to the Batcave we
find that where Bruce urges Dick Grayson
it takes some time for himself following
his retirement from the spy game instead
did grace and vows to help anyone who
will need it operating under the moniker
of Nightwing with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
if you guys have read Nightwing rebirth
let me know what you all think I'm
actually kind of curious and I will
catch you guys on it
you